hey seven and today I'm going to show
you how I fold my shirts so I've got a
plain t-shirt laying out here I'm going
to show you how to fold it quickly and
there you go a perfectly folded shirt
every time
so let me break it down how I did that
falling so you can do it yourself
perfect folded shirt every time I love
my life hacks so this is one of them so
I have my shirt here what I know is I
pinch you look at where the shirt comes
in here the collar and the armpit meet
go a little bit in let me be a
centimeter in and pinch just pinch with
your right hand okay follow this line
down with your left hand and pick up the
shirt bring this all the way to the top
so it's about a little bit off here I'm
going to pick up this side of the shirt
to pull and pull with the right hand
straighten this out put it down on the
ground I forgot what I was doing I'm so
used to doing it fast that I can't do it
slow okay hold on
reset pinch pull straighten okay here's
the mistake so instead of putting it
down like this put it down to the
Cobblers on the floor pull this pull it
over half and you've got the front of
your shirt pick it up above the middle
fold it and there you go perfect shirt
every time you guys liked this video
give it a thumbs up below you have a
question comment leave wait I love
seeing those comments come in thank you
guys so much I'll see you soon